everybody welcome back we are here with
Educators Monica Tyson Crawford and
Laura Street Monica is a bus driver who
saved all 38 students uh when her bus
started to smoke and eventually caught
on fire and I wonder do you think that
any of your kids are going to be
watching this yes I hope they're
watching I hope they will watch yes I
hope they do too want them to see us
cising you and trying to learn about how
to be as a human being and walk through
this world like you in fact we
we hope they're watching and we actually
we we have a little surprise we know
they're watching yeah take a
[Applause]
look say
hi these are all of the students who
were on your bus that day that's right
hi 38
[Applause]
hi how does it feel to see all of them
right there I love them so
much I think we may have two students
Emma and Nolan who wanted to say
something Emma are you there yes
ma'am fine it's fine it's
fine fine it's
fine we'll go through that later it's
fine all right what what would you like
to say to miss
Tyson Dear Miss Tyson I love you because
you got you get us home safely every
single day and you're also our school
mom at Ben Haven Elementary we love
you love you Nolan are you there my
little angel
Nolan yes ma'am hi Nolan um go ahead if
you wanted to say something
too I love you Miss Tyson because you
take us home bring us to school so we
can get an education
oh wow
that is so special and it's not just the
students we also have a parent of one of
the students who wants to say something
Jamie are you there of course I'm here
how are
you hi Jamie hi Jamie what would you
like to
say let me tell you something right now
miss Tyson you are every parent
Str and if it weren't for you there is
no telling what would have happened that
day
and you are a hero today and every day
and what can I say we bus stop
bessies yes we are thank you Emma Nolan
and Jamie and every single of you 38
little delicious angels that we love so
much and we're so happy you're so safe
and also um we teamed up with our
partners at Five Below and they have
been the best Partners this year and
they want to donate donate
$10,000 to
you yeah just to show their appreciation
for everything you
do and everything that you are and also
because they're that kind of company
they didn't stop there um they have got
the whole holidays covered for all the
families involved with great gifts hot
Trends and there's actually just a
little display over there um that's all
going to your students and their family
just to you know keep the holidays
[Applause]
rolling and they they also want to
donate supplies to Ben Haven Elementary
School to help you all stock up as well
thank you so muchow yes and all
encompassing you know all boxes checked
presents a gift to you and supplies for
your school courtesy of Five Below
so blown away by thank you Monica and
thank you Laura Street for
[Music]
everything